how different is florida today versus
back in the days when the mob because
the mob had a lot of uh things they did
in florida this was a hub i mean myron
was doing stuff here back in the days
this was great to go to cuba before you
know things were shut down with the
hotel when lansky was running how how
much of a change is florida today versus
what it was back in the days i mean
there's still guys living down here that
i know of but it was a big spot for us i
mean when we went anywhere we'd come to
florida that was it and i had a big you
know gas operation down here i loved it
down here
but uh different today i mean
everything's different today patrick i
mean it's not the same influence the
same presence anywhere in the country
really even in new york
you know there was a time when i'm not
kidding every single day you pick up the
new york post the new york daily news
there was a mob story
now i read the new york post every
morning online
maybe every six months you'll see
something you know why is that
you know things are changing i mean you
know the the the old guard is gone the
new guys are you know staying undercover
it's not the same as it was before in
any way shape or form look you got to
give the credit to giuliani and uh you
know that whole force back in the mid
80s early to mid 80s when he really
started effectively using the
racketeering act
and put everybody away and changed
everything took the union control away
did did so much damage to that life
which is i guess good for everybody else
but it was bad for the life
and really so this is back in the days
when when you were doing 8 to 12 million
a week how much of it was here how much
of it was new york
well i got indicted down here we were i
think i think it was like 190 million
dollars that they indicted us for down
there we had a big operation down here i
was trying to move most of what we had
up there down here to florida yes when
you say down here what part of florida
all over it's broward yeah okay i guess
yes i just want to revisit something
that you said because i don't want to
gloss over this you said
you got to give respect to rudy giuliani
for what he did so do you respect rudy
is that what you're saying well i didn't
back then you know
tony was going to give me 100 years when
he indicted me but i do now yeah
what changed obviously just age wisdom
no listen you know he was good at what
he did he was better at what he did than
we were what we did at the time so he
got us you know there's no doubt about
it he used it look my case i don't
believe i should have been involved in
that case but he didn't frame me
there was some semblance of something
that he could have indicted me on he did
but i was i was acquitted so i beat it
and it was legitimately acquitted
but uh look you got to give him credit i
mean he was a good prosecutor he knew
what he was doing and uh i think he he
firmly believed that what he was doing
was the right thing so you can't get mad
at somebody like that
how do you process that i mean this is
his biggest competitor you know
you deal with competitors
what does peyton manning say about brady
oh yeah what are you gonna say i mean
the guy is better than you you know how
hard it is for manning to be able to
swallow it and say hey this guy you know
yesterday quote came out about uh
what brady said back in 2012. and a guy
asked the question says man how's it
going to feel when you pass up montana
he says i'm not going after montana i'm
going after jordan
so think about meaning i don't care
about winning five i care about winning
seven right because seven is one more
than michael then it's there he did it
and he did it so and by the way it's
tougher to win seven rings in the nfl
than it is to win six in the nba because
in the nba
you get seven games
so meaning you can have a bad day and
lose to eli manning twice right it ain't
gonna happen in the nba you're not gonna
have four great games yeah you know you
know what i'm saying so but anyways
going to do a quote about uh manning and
brady and then hall of fame inductions
oh yeah yeah well that was uh well
manning's pretty uh pretty funny
obviously everybody knows manning and uh
they would have they had the matchups
where they were in the afc championship
five years in a row and one one of the
pre-games you know manning gave the uh
responsible like what's it like when you
go up against brady he's like well you
know i don't really go up against tom
brady i go up against defense and that's
uh you know so i don't think of it as me
competing against tom brady i got to
beat the defense you don't play safety
and they asked brady the same thing and
he's like yeah i want to kick man exists
absolutely i see every pass he makes and
i need to make i need if he's if he goes
17 for 19 i'm going 18 for 19. that's
that's
by the way manning is super competitive
even from tennessee when he came out the
guys uh people forget how good i think
peyton manning was like like yeah he too
i think it was 2004
he threw
490 passes and had 49 touchdowns one out
of every 10 passes he threw went for a
touchdown the dude was unreal he was
great no doubt he's now is he connected
to the mop is that what we're going with
there's
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye
[Music]